welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and loki just nuked the multiverse
way sooner than we expected
spoiler warning with loki's female
variant releasing
dozens of reset charges across history
and space
causing branch timelines to chaotically
spawn from the sacred timeline
essentially what i wish i could do to my
four years of high school in
jacksonville florida i mean i don't care
how you change it just change it but
back in the tba various dates and
locations show when and where the
variant targeted exactly
and i wanted to dig deeper into these to
explain
why she chose these specific historical
dates and
what exactly might have been altered
both in our planet's real world history
and the history on the other marvel
planets listed here as well
but before i begin thanks to warhammer
40 000 lost crusade for sponsoring this
video
lost crusade is the first mobile
strategy game under the warhammer 40k
title find the link to download the game
in the video's description but first we
have to discuss what this variant just
did
i'm calling her the variant for now
because while she seems to be based on
lady loki from the comics the
international credits lister as sylvie
aka sylvie lushton enchantress
also from that run in the comics so
until we get an answer variant it is
so this variant stole dozens of reset
charges from tva hunters that she has
been murdering
of course the tva uses these to prune
branch timelines that form when variants
step off the sacred timeline
erasing those branches so that the
sacred timeline remains a bare trunk
reaching forward into the future
episode 2 revealed that she's also been
stealing their temp pads these are the
devices that open the doors in time
so hiding in this doomed roxcart
superstore in 2050 the variant has been
rigging all of this tech to
detonate simultaneously dropping these
reset charges throughout history on
planets throughout the universe
causing the sacred timeline to
chaotically split into dozens of new
branches
but hooli reset charges are supposed to
erase branch timelines yet here they're
spawning branches from the sacred
timeline so what's going on
well this confirms that the variant must
know a secret about the timekeepers
that their sacred timeline is actually a
random tapestry of potential branches
that could have formed but each of which
they
chose to canonize as their sacred
timeline
therefore by bombing the sacred timeline
with these reset charges the variant
exposes
that divine stream as just a grab bag of
accidents by erasing dozens of them
allowing in their place to form new
alternate histories instead
and because branches unfold in real time
untouched by each other as explained by
mobius and that multiple choice question
on the computer
those branches do not fill in the erase
parts of the sacred timeline but grow
outward as branches instead essentially
breaking apart the sacred timeline as
they know it so by my count the variant
rigged up at least 42
time bombs and if it is that exact
number you gotta love the shout out to
douglas adams a loki influence i've
cited before
with hitchhiker sky declaring the answer
to the ultimate question of light the
universe and everything
as 42. this video is sponsored by
warhammer 40 000 lost crusade it's a
brand new mmo strategy mobile game where
you're a fleet commander way to
war on all enemies within the imperium
lost crusade is the first mobile
strategy game under the warhammer 40
000 title with an all-new story filled
with characters details and lore that
fans of the 40k franchise will love the
game looks incredible with immersive
visuals and super detailed 3d unit
models
play in real time pve combat build an
alliance with players from all over the
world and get strategic with how you
deploy these troops as you seek to
cleanse the universe of those that defy
the emperor you know space soldier stuff
they got a great voice acting cast for
the game
making it the first time you'll be able
to hear what the official heroes sound
like so download the game using the link
in the description to redeem the code go
to the game's website lostcrusade.com
and click on redeem
code sign in with your account and
select the server you're in
and then enter the gift code rockstar
xlc to claim an in-game gift
but i believe the variant selected each
target as a specific historical
crossroad
a watershed moment in history that set
the sacred timeline on this unique path
and by erasing that piece of the path
and forcing history to diverge in
another direction
that crucial linchpin was broken to make
it especially hard for the tva to fix it
and of course probably stall the tva so
that the variant can infiltrate their
headquarters and get the timekeepers
so let's start with the chrono monitor
ticker nowhere nowhere is the severed
head of a celestial home to the
collector visited in guardians of the
galaxy
no date is shown but it could have
bombed the moment that celestial was
beheaded in ancient times
maybe some history we could soon see as
part of the celestial's origins in the
eternals film but then beside it is
barcelona spain and then below that
nifleheim one of the nine asgardian
realms believed to be
where hella was imprisoned again no date
but maybe this new branch releases hella
early
or could have killed valkyrie instead of
her lover who intercepted hela's attack
to save valkyrie
then dartford england that is the
birthplace of rolling stones members
mick jagger and keith richards so maybe
now we got a timeline with no sympathy
for the devil
then we move on to the specific dates
and places that appear on renslayer's
screen
august 3rd 1522 phangha vietnam so
1522 would have been just before the
europeans arrived in this region
and fangna is famous for its beautiful
cave networks i don't know maybe the
reset triggered an
alternate course of colonial history in
french into china
march 31 1492 lisbon portugal
1492 was a big year for the whole
iberian peninsula columbus's voyage of
course
in the reconquista march 31st in madrid
not lisbon was when the ahama decree was
signed which expelled
jews from spain then april 23 2301
vormir vormir was the location of the
soul stone which nebula once called a
dominion of death at the center of
celestial existence so 2301 would be
hundreds of years
after the events of endgame and the soul
stones atomization but maybe some dark
magic remains here or maybe some
necromancer reanimates gamora and
natasha romanov's remains
also worth mentioning april 23rd could
be a not to infinity wars release date
of april 23rd in the year 2018.
october 25th 1551 thorton usa
now of course there was no usa in 1551
and currently there's no
thorton either there are thorntons but i
wonder if some old vikings settlement
named after the god of thunder
thor's town could have existed in the
americas in early colonial times but was
pruned
until now november 22nd 1999 cookeville
usa that's in tennessee
actually last year a tornado killed 19
people in cookfield tennessee but now
maybe there was gonna be some earlier
tornado in 1999
in a new branch timeline february 16
2004
asgard so 2004 would be eight years
before the events of the first thor
film in asgard and maybe now this branch
is one where thor and odin could have
died in battle and loki ascended to the
throne which could explain that shot in
the trailer with loki on a variant
asgardian throne
october 3rd 1390 rome italy this was
during the great western schism in the
catholic church where he had too many
popes
the roman pope gregory xii the avignon
pope benedict the 13th
and the pisa pope john the 23rd in 1415
gregory the 12th was forced to advocate
in that schism maybe in this branch
timeline he advocates sooner during the
papal jubilee year of 1390
august 13th 1984 sakar teo so sagar is
the trash planet and thor ragnarok home
to the grand masters arena
with teo being the name of that star
system 1984 would have been
23 years before we saw it in ragnarok
and that might have been during the
reign of one of the grandmaster's past
champions who are enshrined on his tower
those included beta ray bill ares man
thing
bye beast and dark crawler so maybe now
in this branch timeline beta ray bill
leads some revolution to become
thor as he does in the comics february
12 1808 barikara colombia so this would
have been right before the republic of
gran colombia declared its independence
from spain
to eventually become what we now know to
be modern-day colombia maybe now this
branch timeline there's a wrench into
that and help spain
maintain its colonies in south america
because with barcelona and madrid on
this list seems like spanish history is
kind of important but then july 14 1700
poor vu finland now during this time
finland was kind of a battleground
between sweden and russia and the great
northern war
and in 1708 porvu was actually sacked
and burned by the russians so maybe this
was a past apocalyptic event the variant
hid
in and now she decided to change
something that happened eight years
before that december 27
1382 ego as in ego the living planet
peter quill's father the celestial
during which time he must have been
planting his seeds all over the galaxy
with various species before meredith
quill
perhaps here he mated with someone else
and caused a whole different bloodline
to either get created or wiped out
october 13th 1982 titan so titan is the
planet that thanos grew up on we saw
that infinity war that also may have
been shown in that tva animation back in
episode one in that uprising that was
led by i'll call him mr variant 1982
would have been about
30 years before thanos's first
appearance in the mcu in about 15 years
before his chronological first
appearance in infinity war when he met
young gamora
so maybe 1982 was the moment that
overpopulation led to the destruction of
titan which would have set thanos
upon his mission and now in this branch
timeline could have either killed off
younger thanos or maybe
saved the planet of titan september 21st
1947 new york
this would have been one month before
the u.n voted on the palestine partition
that created israel but i also think
this is just before steve rogers would
have returned to reunite with peggy in
nearby brooklyn
so maybe there's a timeline where there
was some kind of complication with that
march 1 1984 tokyo this would have been
right at the end of a historic heavy
snowfall in the country that led to 131
deaths this
is also the year that the japanese
doomsday called shinriko was founded but
then
january 3rd 51 a.d hala that's the
earliest date we see on these screens
hala is the cree home world it was
depicted in captain marble
the kree species reached its peak
evolution thousands of years before
humanity did but maybe now some disaster
hits them sooner and stunts their
society's growth or some other kind of
conflict with the skrulls whom they've
always hated
august 2nd 1999 kingsport i don't really
know what this is but that just makes
two random towns in tennessee on this
list
in late 1999 though something must have
happened in that region of the country
then september 24th
1001 zandar so zandar is the home of the
nova corps seen in guardians of the
galaxy
1001 would have been right at the start
of the cre-nova thousand-year war
maybe this branch timeline is ending the
war before it begins by wrecking zandar
since the nova corps sucks and is always
getting defeated in the comics then
november 23
2005 beijing china so i'm not really
sure here but
it would have been two years after the
sars epidemic hit beijing so maybe now
in a new timeline it could resurface
july 18 1903 madrid spain so this would
have been a few years after spain's
defeat in the spanish-american war that
greatly reduced spain's global empire
which historians have said led to the
rise of domestic extremist political
views including those of future dictator
francisco franco
who would have been 11 years old in 1903
so maybe a branch timeline taking him on
a different path above the time door is
in the final seconds yeah portland which
may connect to the pelevious arcade game
that appears in trailer footage
pelevius being a mythical game that
nerds into the portland suburbs in the
80s and 90s believe was part of a
government conspiracy
and then jotunheim loki's home realm the
land of the frost giants like lauffy
loki's father which is why he's named
loki laffy's son son of laufey
actually some of the paperwork that loki
looks through in episode two
lists the name sylvie lauffy
daughter of laufey which may confirm
that sofia dimartino's character is an
alternate timeline loki in which she was
born from laopi as
a girl we'll definitely see more and
more how this timeline has been
specifically left over
in episode three but in the meantime you
can support this channel by checking out
our new loki inspired merch options like
our shirt loki out of time at
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at ea
boss follow new rockstars and subscribe
to the rockstars for loki breakdowns of
everything
loki thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you